عيش التغيير ال ال الاهم اللي بيصير فيها
الملف تحديدا يعني في طبعا بيكون في نظام
جديد لجبايه الزكاه صار يعني في في في
مطبخ الحكومه وفي وفي نقاش وحوار وشد وجذب
مع اخواننا في هيئه الزكاه بين الزملاء
والاخوان صحي جدا لتاكد انه
يحقق ما ذكرته سابقا من سهوله اجراءات
العمل وضوح شفافيه همم يعني ان المستثمر
يعرف اللي له اللي عليه وطبعا بيكون معه
لوائح ونعمل على اللوح جنبنا الى جنب مع
اصدار النظام جبايه الزكاه ننظر في موضوع
الزكاه همم ضريبه الدخل على
الشركات وهمم
يعني قد يكون فيه
مبادرات في هذا الموضوع لن استبرقها لان
خلاص كمل بس الاهم يعني
للاخوان والاخوات اللي معنا يعرفون انه
لدينا الان وضع جيد جيد جدا
سنحسنه ان شاء الله لنصل الى درجه التميز
بالذات في موضوع الاجراءات لانه انا اعتقد
موضوع ال- ال-
موضوع
الزكاه منخفض في المملكه التحدي الان هل
وضوح الاجراءات بالدرجه ال همم مرغوبه
نعتقد انه في مجال التحسين